with so many spider-man movies out there
there are a lot of spider-man villains
we're taking a look back at the many
many supervillains that Spidey's battled
against beware some gigantic spoilers
ahead stop the video now if you're not
up to date on every spider movie the
amazing spider-man 2 is even more than
spider-man 3 before it's an overstuffed
movie that banks on interconnectivity to
help drive excitement for a sequel that
ultimately never came at the time Sony
Pictures was attempting to push ahead
with its own cinematic universe with
spider-man at the heart when it didn't
work we ended up with spider-man in the
MCU watching the amazing spider-man 2
today is mostly an amusing exercise in
seeing someone try to build a universe
that never quite comes together Rhino is
sadly a victim of this crumbling effort
the film had Paul Giamatti playing a
Russian gangster in a mechanical Rhino
suit and the actor clearly relished
chewing up as much scenery as he
possibly could in the role sadly he only
appears in a couple of scenes he might
have had more to do with a hypothetical
sequel but here he's largely an example
of a wasted opportunity the version of
Green Goblin who shows up in the amazing
spider-man 2 is a perfect example of the
film pushing ahead for universe building
while sacrificing any real sense of
long-term storytelling we've never met
this version of Harry Osborn before but
we're told he's got a connection to
Peter going back years we haven't seen
the tallest genetic illness is taking on
him but we're told it's bad and we
should care we haven't seen any real
development in terms of Green Goblin
tech but were shown it all packaged and
ready for Harry to dive in it's a whole
lot of telling without any emotional
weight this lack of real investment
makes this the most forgettable version
of Green Goblin on the big screen so far
making it lecture oh the primary villain
of the amazing spider-man 2 was a good
idea on paper he's got cool powers that
can manifest themselves in interesting
ways visually Andy was played by Jamie
Foxx who offered up a new version of the
character unfortunately it doesn't quite
work Fox seemed to do the best he could
with the material he had but the
characters motivations get lost in the
shuffle of everything else the film is
trying to do by the time electro is
somehow actually playing music with his
powers at the end of the film
he's lost any goodwill he had before
I hate this song
[Music]
venom is a complicated character man
introducing him into any film as a
spider-man antagonist has the potential
to be very tricky business the way
spider-man 3 does it works fine as a
catalyst for the film's climax but
doesn't really let audiences get to know
this particular version of villain and
how he works
there's no time to dig into what the
relationship to the symbiote is or
exactly why Eddie Brock gives in so
quickly or if there's any real humanity
left in him this version of venom is
pretty much just a fight scene and
that's a shame spider-man homecoming the
first solo spider-man adventure in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is a great
example of a film that knows how to
juggle multiple villains without
overwhelming the peace while vulture
does the heavy lifting as the film's
chief bad guy his crew back at
headquarters fits into the story in an
organic and entertaining way however the
tinkerer doesn't rank higher on this
list because he doesn't have that much
to do in the film he's the guy in the
chair manipulating tech and
communications behind the scenes while
the vulture does the fighting because of
that he's not a heavy hitter within the
film but he's certainly entertaining in
the space he's given homecoming manages
to breathe real life into him by making
him a nosy strange guy who's just happy
to have a gig where he can be a huge
tech nerd did I tell you about looking
at my phone oh sorry you left it out you
know I'm gonna carry this person by
Nature the economy of storytelling in
homecoming is so great that the film
manages to fit in not one but two
versions of the Shocker in the film he's
an employee of the vulture who's gifted
with gauntlets that he meant tremendous
energy when they make contact with
someone or something it's enough to make
the characters stand out in his few
fight scenes the first shocker relishes
the idea that he can have a self-giving
codename and go around punching things
with his new toys you're up there
wearing a goofy thing lighten up cars
calling yourself the Shocker
under shocker I shock people what is
this Pro Wrestling and whatever on there
when the second shocker gets ahold of
the gauntlets things become much more
businesslike and the deliberate
calculated way in which he tries to pick
apart Peter Parker is actually rather
chilly together they present a portrait
of a minor super villain that adds
plenty to the film while never getting
in the way of vulture spotlight the
amazing spider-man why is he started
it's new Spidey universe by picking a
villain who'd only been hinted at in the
Sam Raimi films in the form of a
supporting character we'd seen dr. Curt
Connors before but we'd never seen him
transformed into a monster by his own
scientific hubris and desperation the
fact that the character was in the Raimi
films created a sense of excitement
among fans who were finally going to get
to see the lizard while never quite
feeling like the new film was retracing
the steps of the old ones in the Amazing
Spiderman dr. Connors takes on a certain
kind of quiet strangeness that permeates
the early scenes you get the sense that
he's a man who's thought far too much
about things he probably shouldn't be
tinkering with as his slow
transformation begins the character
becomes even stranger creating a villain
who's both threatening and sympathetic
[Music]
the decision to make the Sandman a major
villain in spider-man 3 is an
interesting one particularly when you
consider all the other things the film
is trying to do with Peter Parker's
emotional journey the decision to make
him the guy who killed Uncle Ben off
screen in the first film complicates
this in ways that neither the film nor
the Spider Man mythos really need
despite this this version of The Sandman
works because of the parallels the film
draws between him and Peter they're both
men with strange powers they didn't ask
for pushed into darkness by
circumstances beyond their control and
hoping to atone for their past mistakes
Thomas Haden Church plays the character
with real hearts and his final scene is
one of the most powerful moments in a
flawed film I'm not asking you to
forgive me
I just want you to understand spider-man
3 could have been a film entirely about
the rise of a second Green Goblin in
parallel to Peter Parker wrestling with
the Venom symbiote and it would have
still been a jam-packed movie as it is
we got a film that attempted to juggle
three different villains and cram them
all together into a final fight scene so
Harry Osborn's final journey in the
spider-man trilogy gets crammed in to
still Harry's decision to become the
second Green Goblin in an effort to
avenge his father and then to seek
heroic redemption is a rewarding one it
doesn't always work particularly when
harry has to turn on a dime between hero
and villain in various scenes but the
two preceding films add emotional weight
to a weaker script Willem Dafoe is
having so much fun in the role of Green
Goblin years.before character actors
would begin competing for super villain
roles left and right and his sense of
instant joy of being immersed in the
comic book world is infectious
Dafoe has to transform into full
supervillain mode almost instantly and
somehow he brings it to life flawlessly
what do you want to say but you don't
want to do what you can't he does so
even in spite of the film's shortcomings
and its treatment of the character
something that's particularly obvious in
a costume design the decision to forego
an expressive face for the character and
instead feature a fang baring mask might
have made sense in 2002
unfortunately watching the film today it
makes the scenes with spider-man and the
Goblin look a bit too much like action
figures yelling at each other even in
those moments though the foes voice
carries the performance if you didn't
watch the intro this is where the big
spoilers happen so turn back now
spider-man far from home had to follow a
lot of different very tough acts just
one of which was Michael Keaton's
performance as the vulture the decision
to make the next villain Mysterio
another newcomer to live action
spider-man was a welcome one even better
fans seemed to immediately support Jake
Gyllenhaal's casting as Mysterio a guy
who creates illusions to disguise his
true intentions Gyllenhaal gets a lot of
meaty stuff to play with in the film
from the idea that he first presents
himself as a hero from another dimension
to the revelation that he's a scorned
former employee of Tony Stark the early
more heroic scenes work great but the
turn is where Gyllenhaal really
shines once the gloves are off and he's
in full supervillain mode he's having
the time of his life and so were we
he doesn't quite rise to the heights of
the very best live-action spider-man
villains but he's very close so much so
that even after far from home you can't
help but feel hungry for more of him
with a few notable exceptions Sam
Raimi's spider-man films are often
defined by their aesthetic and
structural devotion to the Marvel Comics
book they're based on the key to the
best of these films is the way in which
they know exactly how to deviate and win
with spider-man 2 we get the best of
both worlds in Doctor Octopus he's a guy
who looks and moves exactly how we'd
expect the comic book version to move
and he has the added gravitas of a good
man corrupted by his own creation Alfred
Molina is flawless as dr. octo Octavius
a scientist who's hoping to change the
world before his brain is infected by
the artificial intelligence in his
robotic extra arms after a horrible
accident riddled with guilt and grief
Molina plays the disintegration of the
character perfectly then manages to
guide him back to Redemption with the
same sense of vulnerability and delicate
emotional resonance it's a great
performance in a great comic book movie
sometimes spider-man's stories are at
their very best when they take a very
simple easy-to-follow metaphor and
translate it into the big bold strokes
of a superhero story
spider-man homecoming is a story about
Peter Parker finding out his
girlfriend's dad is a jerk and the jerk
is played to perfection by Michael
Keaton there's so much to love about the
vulture and homecoming from the look of
the character to the way Keaton plays
him as a working-class guy who got tired
of being pushed around
there's no nonsense here but there are
tricky emotional turns to make and
Keaton manages them all by being equal
parts charming and terrifying the scene
in which he has a private moment with
Peter in his car is among the best
moments in any Spiderman pill Hey
and just save your life you know what do
you say
thank you even better the fact that his
character actually has a point about the
way regular people are pushed down in an
increasingly strange world only adds to
his impact it's a brilliant layered
performance that's going to be hard to
top check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Spider Man far from home or coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]